respectfully the Saudi Crown Prince
Muhammad bin Salman is speaking in Riyad
Salman to welcome you to your second
Homeland and to convey his wishes for
the success of this Summit which comes
amid dire
painful time as we reiterate our
condemnation of This ferocious brutal
War under which our Palestinian brothers
are railing as a result of which
thousands of civilians were killed
Hospital
places of workship worship were
destroyed the kingdom has been
exerting concerted efforts continue to
consult and coordinate with brother and
friendly states to put an end to this
war and based on this we immediately
call for the cease of military operation
provision of military uh provision of
humanitarian cor Corridor and release of
captives and prisoners and spare of
innocent vant lives this is a
humanitarian catastrophe that proved the
failure of the International Community
and the security Council to put an end
to Israel's gross violations of
international laws and international
humanitarian law and proves the Dual
standards adopted by the world that will
undermine peace and security of the
world this requires us to concerted
efforts and effective actions in the
face of this painful regretful and we
call for the end of Siege delivery of
Aid Medical supplies and provision of
other supplies and the exit of the
victims and patients we reiterate our
rejection of the aggression and
forceable transfer of the citizens and
we hold the Israeli occupation forces
authorities for the crimes against the
Palestinian peoples we are certain that
the only cause for peace is the end of
the Israeli occupation Siege and illegal
settlement and restoration of the
established lawful right rights of the
Palestinian people and the establishment
of their state on 1967 portal with East
Jerusalem at its capital this will
guarantee the peace and security of the
region and the states within thank
you I give the floor to the Secretary
General of the league of Arab states
ahed Your Highness Prince Muhammad B Sal
ABD Al the Crown Prince and prime
minister of Saudi Arabia your majesties
your highnesses
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen
Israel's war on Gaza Strip is not the
first yet we all hope and wish it will
be the last Israel from day one to
occupy the strip and to have the
population expelled or transferred their
sick wishes reached one of their racist
ministers to Nuke the strip to that
extent the Israeli h
has come against unarmed civilian
Palestinian who deserve all appreciation
and support as we speak Israel has
killed more than 11,000 civilians 70% of
whom are women and children it is a
genocide and ethnic cleansing systematic
violence campaign under the eyes of the
whole world violence and blood that will
seed
more hatred for the generations to come
we call on the United Nations security
Council to relieve the Palestinian from
the ferociousness of this war yet
failure after another as particular
forces refuse to stand up to Israel to
put an end to their aggression against
what has happened on October 7
justifying these crimes as self-defense
I have three major points bullet points
to
stress first the cease fire total and
Lasting is a priority which should be
worked towards priority that transcends
above any other
consideration we should those who work
towards preventing the expansion of War
should realize that the continued
killing machine of Israel will raise the
possibilities of regional confrontation
second the total the forceable transfer
of the people of a strip is an
international War crime and flagrant
violation of the international
humanitarian law rejected by the
Palestinians the Arabs and the whole
world yet the Israeli radical forces do
not wish to abandon their wishes to have
a second transfer which will
not happen and we cannot allow this to
happen to achieve these fascist wishes
third we cannot speak about the future
of Gaza without speaking of the future
of West Bank and the OCC East Jerusalem
these are the parts of the Palestinian
State on the basis of
borders addressing the security and
Military solution towards Gaza without
any political or or diplomatic Horizon
is a waste of more time and it will
result in bringing us back to square one
your
highnesses your excellencies ladies and
gentlemen some Western State and started
to respond to the idea of holding an
International Peace conference to
address the root causes of the conflict
based on the two-state solution despite
the unbalanced dual standards that
represented a shock To Us by a number of
states and officials yet the
international public opinion is waking
up as it has waken up to the Ferocious
per program s perpetrated by the Israeli
occupation forces I believe that we
should respond with those responding to
the call for International Peace
conference which will pave the way for
diplomatic course that will lead to the
establishment of the two State solution
bringing uh matters back to the course
will be difficult and long all the
states will no doubt extend all the
possible assistant the Palestinians and
the gazans
deserve finally we pray to God Almighty
to Grant Solace to families of the
victims and to accept in his Mercy all
the Fallen Martyrs and here we should
salute the memory of late president Tas
arat who the anniversary of his death
coincides with today and we join the
world voices calling for the cease of
this war immediately with without
further delay thank
you